president Trump surprises the world by
brokering a meeting with Kim jong-un the
dictator of North Korea he rolls out his
big tariff plan and we will check the
mailbag i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
every news cycle is now 33.3
milliseconds long that's how fast the
news moves these days yesterday there
are a bevy of headlines coming out of
the Trump administration we'll get to
all of them will do full analysis of the
president's big announcement that he
wants to meet with Kim jong-un the
dictator of North Korea in just a second
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at blue apron so everyone
in the office is using blue apron people
all over the country are using blue
apron and that's for a reason blue apron
is the leading meal kit delivery service
in the United States and here's the way
that it works they send you the freshest
ingredients all prepackaged in the
proper amounts and you sit in your house
and you cook with your family there's no
more fun thing and cooking with your
kids I know I do with my daughter all
the time it's a blast and not only that
when you cook that fresh home-cooked
meal it just tastes better it's better
to eat at home with the kids now I'm in
a situation in my house where I've got
such young children when we go to a
restaurant there's a good shot that some
table is gonna get pushed over so eating
at home is a must when you have young
kids there's nothing better than eating
at home and there's nothing easier than
making it happen
with blue apron they're the number one
fresh ingredient and recipe delivery
service in the country they offer a wide
variety of plans they offer convenience
and variety they deliver fresh
pre-portion ingredients step-by-step
recipes right to your door these can be
cooked in under 45 minutes the menu
changes every single week based on
what's in season it's designed by blue
aprons in-house kuelen Airy team and
they offer 12 new recipes every week
customers can pick two three four
recipes depending on what best fits your
schedule and of course they send only
the highest quality ingredients it's
just awesome and blue apron is treating
Ben Shapiro listeners 230 bucks off your
first order if you visit blue apron com
slash up here oh that's blue apron calm
slash Shapiro we're talking about meals
that make you feel like a gourmet
hugging pan-fried chicken breast with
sweet and tangy zucchini quick you
Kotani with broccoli and pecorino cheese
don't know what that is but I'm looking
at picture of it it looks amazing
the Italian style shrimp and sweet
peppers good for my non-jewish friends
over for Go la serda pasta so many
amazing sounding meals and you'll be
making these in your house with the
greatest of ease blue aprons come /
capiro means they're getting 30 bucks
off your first order when you use that
slash up here a blue apron is a better
way to cook again it's fresher
ingredients it tastes better and it's
more fun the family the cooks together
stays together blue apron calm / Shapiro
again get the
dollars off and let them know that we
sent you by using that slash Shapiro
okay so the big announcement yesterday
from the Trump administration is that
President Trump was now open to meeting
with Kim jong-un and they were
attempting to broker some sort of
meeting maybe in Pyongyang maybe in the
middle of North Korea it's possible
they're talking about the president
doing this in May well there are a few
issues with this and and it's very
interesting to watch as the right and
the left split on this issue because the
left cheered when President Obama you
remember one who's Senator Obama in 2008
in a speech he said that he would meet
with the leaders of Iran North Korea
without preconditions and he would meet
with them without getting anything in
return to even sit at the table with
them and a lot of people people like me
said that's terrible why would you
possibly do that because now you're
giving legitimacy to evil regimes
without them having to give up anything
and well now President Trump seems to be
doing some of the same sort of stuff and
people on the right are split they're
bunch of people on the right who think
this is just great and a bunch of people
on the right who think it's kind of
stinks and then they're a bunch of folks
on the Left who celebrated when Obama
said that oh look at that it's a new
open foreign policy it's just gonna be
amazing
and now Trump's doing it and they're
confused are they supposed to be mad or
are they supposed to be happy and so
you're seeing this bizarre split in
alliances among political allies and and
weird new alliances forming among
political enemies all about Trump
meeting with Kim jong-un so first we
have to do a little bit of background
here so Kim jong-un obviously is the
dictator of the most repressive country
on planet earth it is basically a giant
gulag thousands of people are still in
prison camps today under Kim jong-un and
he has obviously been threatening the
world with nuclear weapons he's been
test firing ICBMs intercontinental
ballistic missiles that are apparently
capable of hitting the United States
he's been testing more and more powerful
nuclear weapons he's been threatening
shipping lanes and he's been using
bellicose language toward South Korea
now what's weird is that South Korea has
moved in the direction of appeasement so
they've elected their own sort of
Neville Chamberlain figure that would be
the president of North Korea whose name
is moon and the presidents of North
Korea is committed to what he calls a
sunlight policy the sunlight policy is a
policy of date ons with the North
Koreans president moon jae-in is
actually the guy who conveyed Kim's
supporters supposed to offer to meet to
the Americans his office said that North
Korea quote has ample intention
holding talks with the United States and
he has another agenda here which is that
he is not particularly fond of the US
having a military presence in South
Korea now it is the u.s. military
presence in South Korea that essentially
guarantees there's not another Korean
War it's the American presence in South
Korea that guarantees that North Korea
may be with Chinese support doesn't walk
across that 38th parallel and just walk
right into the heart of Seoul because
the fact is that the United States has a
trigger mechanism in foreign policy we
have a trigger mechanism meaning that we
have a certain number of troops that are
along the border and if that border were
to be breached the United States would
immediately be meshed in a war with the
North Koreans the North Koreans know
that and they know the minute they step
over the border the United States comes
in and Visser eights them and that's the
end of that war if the United States
were to remove support from the South
Koreans the calculus would change very
quickly and at the very least the North
Koreans and the Chinese could pressure
the South Koreans for all sorts of
concessions they could push them into
their own sphere of influence on train
on defense it could get very ugly very
quickly without the u.s. continuing to
be there and in a line with the South
Koreans on a military level but the
current regime in South Korea the
current administration in South Korea is
not real fond of that they don't want
the United States deploying anti-missile
technology in South Korea they don't
want the United States deploying troops
in South Korea and so they're honestly
sort of working on behalf of the North
Koreans to make a move that would push
the United States out to the fringe on
South Korean on South Korean ground so
all of that is the background of course
Trump has been using very bellicose
language with regard to the North
Koreans the North Koreans been using
bellicose language with regard to trump
they've basically been tweeting at each
other Trump tweeted that he has a bigger
button than Kim jong-un which is
obviously true and Kim jong-un has said
that the United States will bathe and
fire and all this kind of stuff and so
the the talking point for people who are
big Trump fans is that Trump forced the
North Koreans to the table with all of
this language that Trump showed he
wasn't gonna budge and now the North
Koreans are gonna come to the table and
they're gonna cave that seems unlikely
to me it seems more like this is a
calculated ploy by the curb by the North
Koreans to gain concessions from the
West in exchange for an empty promise
the reason I say this is because this
has been the North Korean way of doing
business for nigh on 60 years at this
point they've constantly threatened the
West they've constantly gotten
concessions they've constantly gotten
cash and food and even nuclear help
under the 1994 framework North Korea
by Bill Clinton and Jimmy Carter under
all of that the North Koreans have
always gains and the West has always
lost the North Koreans have never felt
the need to give up their nuclear
program they've continued to progress
their nuclear program even as we
continue to sign checks to them so this
all started yesterday with the South
Korean security adviser cheung yu-yan i
think i'm pronouncing that wrong but he
said that North Korea is now committed
to denuclearization I'll explain what he
means by this in a second because if you
read the headline that sounds great
North Korea's gonna get rid of its nukes
if you know what he means not that great
here's what he had to say president in
our meeting North Korean leader Kim
jong-un said he is committed to Teague
polarization Kim pledged that North
Korea will refrain from any photo okay
so basically that's the South Korean
government saying well Kim said he's not
gonna fire any more ICBM they're testing
any more missiles well we're not super
worried about the test at this point
we're worried about the continued
development of the technology because he
can restart the test anytime he wants I
promise to stop tests so that he can get
in the room with Trump and get a picture
walking out with Trump and show his own
people that he is a powerful leader on
par with Trump is is fine with him I
mean if that means six weeks of
refraining from firing missiles he can
probably handle that remember it's
already the middle of March May is
coming up really quickly so all he asked
it so basically he's promised that for
the next six weeks he won't fire a
missile look D do what do you do when he
says that North Korea is committed to
denuclearization understand the absolute
stated program of the North Korean
government is we want denuclearization
of the entire peninsula what that means
is we want the United States to remove
its troops from South Korea so we'll get
rid of our nuclear program if and only
if the United States removes its troops
from South Korea and the United States
stops engaging in military exercises
with the South Koreans I think that
Kimmel wants to make that pitch directly
to Trump he wants to say listen we can
walk out of here with the greatest deal
you'll win the Nobel Peace Prize right
we'll walk out of here and you'll have
been the guy who disarmed the Kim regime
had all been the guy who allowed the
Korean Peninsula to finally stand up on
its own
you can make a nationalist appeal to
Trump and it would be a bad move by
Trump because again if the United States
does not have troops in South Korea this
radically changes the situation on the
ground not only militarily but in terms
of economics and trade in terms of
foreign policy spheres of influence
protection of particular trade corridors
but all of this goes in by the wayside
if the United States were to pull its
troops out of South Korea which is why
we've never really considered it before
it's possible however that Trump falls
for that routine so the question in
Trump meeting with North Korea is is
this Trump and Gorbachev right is this
Reagan and Gorbachev or Reagan basically
strong arms Gorbachev and refuses to
make concessions to Gorbachev or is this
Nixon to China is this Trump goes to the
North Koreans and the North Koreans lied
to him and then he buys it because now
he's gonna get a political win out of it
well it certainly sounds like Trump is
very positive about all this he sees
this as a big one
here's Trump talking about North Korea
acting very positively all of a sudden
whether to see they seem to be acting
positively but we're gonna see well no
one I'm willing to go as you probably
noticed this morning where we sent out
through social media statement willing
to go either way hopefully it's going to
be the proper way the proper way is the
way that everybody knows and everybody
wants okay so yeah this is all very nice
and very happy Dappy Doo he tweeted
something out similar yesterday about
about North Koreans said great progress
is being made as if Kim jong-un talked
about denuclearization with the South
Korean representatives not just a freeze
also no missile testing by North Korea
during this period of time great
progress being made but sanctions will
remain until an agreement has reached
meeting being planned okay so he sounds
very positive about all of this and the
way that Trump fans are playing this is
that Trump has won right the little
rocket man blinked this is what Sean
Hannity says that Trump has his
shellacked kim jeong-hoon into surrender
of course this is what Sean is gonna say
Sean is a big Trump fan obviously he
thinks everything Trump does is a work
of magnificent genius here was his take
major breaking news tonight a huge
foreign policy win for president Trump
little rocket man blinks now the
president's tough rhetoric his bold
action his severe sanctions they appear
to be working tonight president Trump is
accepting an invitation to meet with the
North Korean dictator Kim jong-un by May
and Pyongyang is agreeing to stop all
nuclear and missile tests while these
talks are under way and the sanctions
they will continue okay that is
not exactly the correct take I think I
think the idea that that there is a big
blink here by a Kim the question is what
it's Kim giving up and the answer is
nothing I can get Kim is giving up
nothing and he's gonna get a picture
with Trump walking out arm and arm hands
out raised right like Neville
Chamberlain and Adolf Hitler and you
know that that's that's a real
possibility the question here is are
those fabled negotiation skills of Trump
so magical is he really gonna be able to
get to a room with Kim and then get him
to denuclearize and we were obtained all
of our troops there we still have
sanctions that snap back into place if
something should go wrong we still have
verifiability of their demonization are
all those things really gonna happen do
you think they're really gonna happen
because I'm very skeptical they're gonna
happen I'm very skeptical the Kim regime
is going to give up all of that just
because Trump tweeted some nasty things
about Kim it doesn't make any real
politic sense like plagued him for a
second put yourself get yourself out of
the American political context and play
Kim for a second if you are the Kim
regime how exactly would you play this
I'll explain what you would do if you
were the Kim regime and why I'm so
skeptical that anything is gonna come
out of this that's positive for the
United States in just a second but first
I want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at filter by so and the the reality
is that right now it is very cold
outside you're spending a lot of time
inside and because you're spending a lot
of time inside you are breathing in a
lot of filtered air well filtered air
very often is dirtier than the air
outside but it doesn't have to be that
way
filter by is America's leading provider
of HVAC filters for homes and small
businesses and they want you to breathe
better they carry over 600 different
filter sizes including custom options
all ship free within 24 hours plus they
are manufactured right here in the
United States they offer a multitude of
any RV options all the way up to
hospital grade so you're removing that
dangerous pollen the mold the dust the
other allergy aggravating pollution
while maximizing the efficiency of your
system and just as importantly they have
a subscription plan so when you order
those filters they will be refreshed
every so often insuring that you are
never breathing unclean air that you put
in the new filters and forget about it
for three years you look at it and it's
filled with mold that's never gonna
happen again when you get on their
subscription plan right now you can get
5% when you set up auto delivery so you
never need to think about those air
filters again breathe better with filter
by calm it's filter bu why calm that's
filter bu why calm and right now again
when you when you order through filter
by comm you save 5% when you set up that
auto delivery system and again I'll
order ship free within 24
our 600 size options make sure that the
air that you and your family everything
is clean it's just the least you can do
to make sure that your kids are healthy
so check it out at filter by con make
sure you're healthy as well obviously
filter by comm filter B wide comm get 5%
off when you get that when you get that
auto auto delivery program okay so
imagine that you are kim jeong-hoon for
a second let's get out of trim set we
spend so much time in American politics
in the head of Donald Trump which is a
weird place now let's be real it's kind
of a weird place and even weirder places
the Kim regime but I'm not convinced and
I've never been convinced that the Kim
regime is crazy I've never been
convinced that Kim jong-un is a crazy
guy it seems to me that he is a person
who is out for self preservation and
preservation of his evil regime now if
you are him and you are looking around
if you were he and you were looking
around at the world and you were
thinking yourself how can I ensure that
I maintain power and then I stay in
power for the rest of my life the first
thing you would do is develop nuclear
weapons and that is the very first thing
that you would do because that would
ensure that there is a deterrent that
should the United States attack you he
threatened a nuke Seoul and that's the
end of it right you get to stay because
no one wants someone moved no one wants
a hundred thousand people dead in the
middle of Seoul even if it means
liberating North Korean the the North
Korean people have been subjugated for
decades on it so you want your nuclear
weapons but what you also want is
economic support from the West you want
them signing checks to you and so what
you do is every so often you offer to
give up your nuclear weapons and you say
you know we'll give those things right
up you know we'll make concessions to
you just sign us some checks remove the
sanctions sign us some checks we won't
do any we won't do any testing we won't
fire missiles we won't test start our
bombs and then you spend the next three
years in the bunker developing new
weapons and then three years later you
come out you do the same routine and
there are new sanctions in another round
of sanctions and you've shown the world
that you're strong that they get in
there deterred that's the way this logic
works it's not illogical what Kim is
doing it's not
I mean threatening the United States
sounds illogical it's not illogical
because the whole point of him
threatening the United States is to
prevent the United States from invading
his country and sacking him or to
prevent the the North Koreans themselves
from sacking him hey that's the whole
that's the whole point here so why does
he want to meet with Trump because again
it gives him that sort of legitimacy now
what's again what's funny is you're
seeing the left-wing media very excited
about all this Erin Burnett said
from solves North Korea he will be seen
as a great president here's what she had
to say all right well thanks very much
to all of you just an extraordinary
evening and of course opening the door
to the big question President Trump can
truly solve this problem that would be
going down as a great president and
there's no way around that that is the
reality here okay well is that the
reality or is it just that you are going
to celebrate that and if that's the case
that's what Trump is going for if what
Trump really wants out of life is this
big win then I'm not sure exactly you
know how he doesn't get played by him
the way that you negotiate best is when
you're willing to walk away from the
table the question now is Trump gonna be
willing to walk away from the table
that's questionable that's questionable
I'll explain why in just second so there
are a bunch of good commentary pieces
out about what's happening right now the
biggest problem here is that you can see
a situation which Trump goes into the
meeting an offer is made by Kim it's not
a good offer it's an offer like get all
the troops out of South Korea and we
will denuclearize and Trump says sure
let's do it because he'll I don't really
like this alliance with South Korea all
that much anyway I've made noises along
those lines there's a good piece by
Thomas right over at the Atlantic
talking about all of us pointing out
that Trump is not oriented toward the
alliance with North Korea in a
particularly strong way he right says
since the mid 1980s he's argued that
America's alliance is our bad deal
initially his wrath was focused on Japan
and the Arab states but in 2013 he said
how long will we go on defending South
Korea from North Korea without payment
when will they start to pay us and then
he said in 2015 we have 28,000 soldiers
on the line in South Korea between the
madman and them we get practically
nothing compared to the cost of this so
maybe he will get to withdraw troops
which he wants in exchange for an anti
ICBM testing which he also wants you
could see Trump making the steel it
would be bad for the United States
because that's bad policy it's possible
that he plays this as America first and
it's also possible that Trump is ego
invested and that wouldn't be unique to
Trump one of the big problems with
meeting with dictators like the
dictators of Iran one of the biggest
problems here is that when you do that
you end up in a situation where if you
do not proclaim a win it is seen as a
political loss so when President Obama
spent an awful lot of time negotiating a
deal with the Iranian mullahs with it
with the worst people on earth it gave
him a steak and then proclaiming that
they were not actually violating law it
gave him a stake in pretending that Iran
was a moderate States
the whole pitch in Iran those pushed by
Ben Rhodes that liar that liar Pyrex
Ilan's the lie was that the Iranians had
moderated and that they wanted to meet
with us because they had moderated and
then we made concessions to them because
they had moderated and our concessions
would make them further moderate none of
that was true they're just as extreme
and radical and evil as they always have
been the Iranian government has always
been this they've not changed one iota
they have if anything strengthened their
Proterra regime but all of Obama's
acolytes will still tell you that Obama
maintained the moderation of the regime
that Obama pushed that regime toward the
center the reason being that Obama was
invested in the success of his deal and
if it turned out that Iran basically
just screwed him and took the money and
ran then Obama looks like a sucker well
Trump may feel the same sort of thing if
he gets in a room with Kim there's two
possibilities he walks out of the room
pissed or he walks out feeling like he's
won something the media cheer him he was
you know about Peace Prize and then he
spends the rest of his presidency
talking about North Korea has moderated
under his influence that's a serious
possibility here and it's not a serious
reality I just don't think North Korea
is gonna is gonna change anytime soon I
don't think they're gonna open up I
don't think that we're looking at
Gorbachev in Kim jong-un I don't think
that we're looking at anything remotely
like that now again maybe I'm totally
wrong it's possible it's possible that
Trump is the creature of genius that his
supporters suggest he is no Rothman at
commentary says sometimes it takes an
outsider unburdened by the stifling
conventions and preconceptions that
impede the practice of diplomacy to see
the obvious Trump is that outsider
sometimes Trump's distance from
diplomacy's precepts allow him to see
its hobgoblins as they are that was the
case when his administration threw away
custom by deciding again to consign
North Korea to the list of state terror
sponsors to institute a renewed
sanctions regime targeting Iran and to
move the US Embassy to Jerusalem that's
no drop and by the way is not a Trump
fan he really does not like Trump but
what he's saying here is possible right
the risk that professional diplomats
feared would result from these maneuvers
never materialized and only a risk prone
executive could have achieved these
successes Trump's particular facility is
not without its dangers
sometimes the conventional wisdom for is
conventional for a wheeze for a reason
Donald Trump's decision to sit down with
North Korea's Kim jong-eun of
Pyongyang's request for example is
fraught with more potential for risk
than reward so here is the risk he says
on Thursday night Trump said that he'd
received a letter from the North Korean
despot from the South Koreans and he
said that he had been willing to sit
down
with him and Trump's defenders say that
this isn't a concession but here's the
problem the arrangement is already a
lopsided one in North Korea's favor and
the stakes only get higher from here
this is the big one it's a gambit that
could pay off but the United States gets
only one shot at this if it fails
American losses will not be minimal the
meeting between the leader of the free
world and the criminal proprietor of the
world's largest open-air prison might
produce a breakthrough Trump might
convince Kim to agree to the permanent
and verifiable dismantling of his
nuclear program thus surrendering the
only leverage they got North Korea to
the table in the first place Kim's
long-range missile program might be on
the table for the first time in 20 years
in exchange Trump could offer diplomatic
recognition a peace treaty or sanctions
relief a grand bargain is possible in
theory but but is that likely is that
likely it could also if the maneuver
were to fail or return to dialogue at
lower functionary levels or even through
backchannels might be regarded as a
fruitless pursuit which leaves the
United States the only one viable waits
neutralized in the North Korean nuclear
program so there's a lot of risk to all
of this again I don't think Trump is
versed enough in these things to pull
off a major diplomatic coup I am
perfectly happy to change my mind if he
does so I'm open to the idea that this
is all a work of genius it's possible do
I think that it's likely I I do not
think that it is likely I think this is
more risk than reward and I think that
again this comes down more to political
considerations than it does to genius
manipulation of the North Korean regime
okay so before I go any further on talk
about Trump on tariffs Trump has
announced his new tariff program
yesterday which is not great I want to
discuss our new advertisers over it
keeps so keeps is the easiest way to
keep your hair hey the fact is that if
you have hair loss in your family
there's a good shot that you are going
to lose your hair as well guys it starts
really early and once that hair starts
to go it ain't coming back and that's
why it's important that you preemptively
strike with keeps it keeps offers the
only two hair loss products that are
clinically proven to keep the hair that
you have you can sign up in less than
five minutes it's entirely online it's
only $10 to $35 a month
normally this sort of medication goes
for like 85 bucks okay this is half of
what you would typically pay at the
pharmacy
getting started with keeps is really
easy so you just answer a few questions
and you snap some photos I've done it
myself you snap some photos at the top
of your head and you send them in and
then a licensed doctor remotely reviews
your information and gives you the right
prescription all without ever leaving
your couch within two to three
a three-month supply of your treatment
will arrive perfectly packaged at your
door there are only two treatments that
are FDA licensed and keeps offers both
of them stop hair loss today the easy
way with keeps offering customized
treatment plans with the only clinically
proven hair loss products for about a
buck a day from the comfort of your
couch to receive your first month of
treatment for free go to keeps calm / -
pretty awesome deal keeps calm / man
that is ke EPS calm / been a free month
of treatment at keeps calm / man it
keeps your hair today because if you
don't do it today it's going to be gone
tomorrow again even if you have your
hair right now then you should be you
know weary if your dad is missing his
for example so make sure that you get
started now and you know Dad that here's
a useful thing to have keeps calm / been
and you get a month of treatment for
free again this is all through licensed
doctors who review your information so
check that out keeps calm / pen I use it
myself it's great okay so meanwhile the
President of the United States has
announced that he is doing his tariff
plan so I've spent the last several days
talking about why tariffs are bad policy
yeah if he are still confused about that
go back and listen to the other podcast
the short story is that basically a
tariff is a tax that taxes all other
Americans on behalf of one industry so
if you are not in the steel industry and
you are in the car industry then you
just got taxed your industry is going to
lose jobs because the steel cost that
went into the making of your car just
went up in order to benefit the steel
industry so Trump only has authority to
do this under a fifty-year-old law and
gives him the ability to say that
national security concerns are driving
him on tariffs so here is from
proclaiming that this was a security
consideration it is by the way not a
security consideration it is pretty
clearly not a security consideration in
any serious way any of the fact is that
well over seventy percent of all
American steel consumed in the United
States is American meaning that all the
steel that we consume is American steel
the amount that's coming from China is
like two percent on the countries that
are most affected by these tariffs are
importing six percent total of America's
steel because Trump has now exempted
Canada and Mexico so it's amazing the
same guy who said that NAFTA is a real
boondoggle is saying that we have to
ensure that Canada and Mexico can still
ship steel into the United States Canada
is the number one importer of steel
exporter of steel from Canada into the
United States
again none of this is good economic
policy it is worth noting by the way the
Trump economy is booming okay so in
February we gain three hundred and
thirteen thousand jobs that is a massive
number of jobs
okay the Bureau of Labor Statistics
after revisions job gains to the average
two hundred forty two thousand over the
last three months wages continue to rise
for the first time in a long time
in February the average hourly earnings
for all employees on private non-farm
payrolls rose by four cents following a
seven cent gain in January over the year
average hourly earnings have increased
by sixty eight cents or two point six
percent which is not insignificant the
number of Americans not in the labor
force is still ninety five million so
that has maintained but that's including
a lot of people who are retired that's
including a lot of people who have gone
on unemployment it's basically the same
numbers under Obama's the economy
continues to boom economists had
expected two hundred thousand jobs to be
created in February instead it's well
over three hundred thousand it's three
hundred thirty thousand so why would
this be the best time for the president
to undermine the economy with a set of
tariffs that are sure to Rock the
markets that doesn't make a lot of sense
but here's from saying that he's doing
it for security reasons the actions were
taking today are not a matter of choice
they're a matter of necessity for our
security we're already seeing the
national security benefits of this order
okay that is not true the idea that that
it is a national security concern is
wrong the United States was not a the
United States shifted its entire car
industry into steel making for tanks
during World War two during the entirety
of World War two her the statistic
yesterday blew me away during the
entirety of World War two only about
three hundred cars were manufactured in
the United States total because there
was no one here to drive them and all of
the manufacturing production was shifted
to war making ability if you think the
United States cannot supply its war
making material what the steel industry
we've got at home
it's because you don't know anything
about the American steel industry we are
producing exactly the same amount of
Steel that we did in nineteen
eighty-three okay so far it's been it's
been absolutely constant for nearly 40
years it's just it's just ridiculous to
suggest this is a real security concern
it's not Congress should step in and do
something they probably won't the the
best moments of this by the way the best
moment of trumps announcement yesterday
on steel was this I just this is so
fantastic it is this is pure Trump okay
it does not get better than this so
Trump is talking to a bunch of steel
workers a bunch of the union members by
the way have said that they they love
this they're very happy that the Trump
was talking to a member of the steel
workers union and and this was hilarious
so he says to the guy that your dad is
really proud of you looking down from
heaven watch this it's just it's not
important but it is really really funny
and it's it's big Trump this is big
Trump right here Herman is looking down
he's very proud of you right that is
even more proud
[Applause]
your father is looking down no my dad's
still alive man gotta love it
gotta love it pretty spectacular again
that says nothing about Trump per se
it's just really really funny it's like
when Joe Biden said it to rally that he
asked a guy who's a paraplegic to stand
up and take a bow it's just just
spectacular stuff from the President of
the United States right there the steel
workers unions are of course very happy
the afl-cio is very happy now I was of
the impression that a bunch of people on
the right were not real fans of the
afl-cio one of the big Democrats
supporting unions in American history
that when you please the unions that you
are actually pleasing the people who
least support free markets right this
this was my impression but Trump is of
course very happy to reach out to those
unions he thinks this is gonna win him
Indiana he thinks this is known in
Pennsylvania again what he doesn't
understand is that all of the same
states that that he is targeting are
also damaged by steel tariffs because
there are a lot of jobs in those states
that are reliant on industries that are
gonna be hurt by the steel tariffs
themselves this is the map that people
that in the administration had showed
Trump I mean they showed him they're a
bunch of Rust Belt states that actually
lose thanks to his tariff proposals but
Trump apparently decided to buck them
anyway because he thinks that he's gonna
be able to have stories about steel
workers you know smelting again Leo
Gerard is a member of one of these steel
workers unions he says we've been
fighting this for thirty years and
that's why it is the United Steel
Workers this is why we are so happy
about president Trump's tariff plans leo
but what do you say to these folks out
there they're saying why are we
protecting a handful of jobs when it's
gonna make everything else more
expensive for the majority of Americans
cut we're doing it because to tell you
the truth they don't know what the hell
they're talking about
we've been fighting this fight for 30
years and for 30 years the American
steel industry the American lumina
ministry has been under attack
cut by countries that don't play by the
rules okay so a couple of things that
are worth noting here so the language of
don't play by the rules is kind of a
weird language so what rules are they
not playing by if the idea is that you
know
States has different environmental
regulations than China obviously that's
true but is that a change in the rules
and is the idea that everybody in the
United States is supposed to pay for a
less competitive industry when another
industry is subsidized overseas this is
not the way that the trade typically
work so our people in the steel industry
damaged by so-called unfair trade
practices from China you know China
using manual using manual labor in China
China subsidizing its industries there's
no question that the steel industry in
the United States is damaged by that now
it is true the vast majority of jobs
that have been lost in the steel
industry have not been lost
thanks to Chinese competition they've
been lost thanks to technology because
the United States has actually gotten
stronger in its steel industry because
they've developed new technologies that
make us more competitive it's one of the
reasons why competition open competition
is better punishing the rest of the
United States because China has lower
environmental regulations in order to
save a particular industry I'm not sure
what makes the steel industry any more
special than farming I'm not sure what
makes farming any more special than
health care I'm not sure what makes
health care any more special than media
a job is a job as a job in the United
States and there's a good case to be
made that a lot of the people who say
they would be happy working in the steel
industry would be a lot happier not
working in the steel industry if the
shift of jobs in the United States is
any indicator and people tend to be
happier with their jobs now than they
were 40 years ago well all of that said
is it true that there are a bunch of
countries that have subsidized their own
steel regimes in order to their their
own steel industries in or to undercut
the United States the answer is yes but
the solution to that is not necessarily
for us to try to reciprocally harm those
countries and just because of those
countries decide to tax their own
citizens in order to benefit the steel
industry doesn't mean that we have to do
the same and that seems like foolish
policy to me and just because they
decide to cut off their own economy the
needs to help their steel industry grow
doesn't mean that we ought to do the
same economies are more than steel
obviously so we're gonna discuss this a
little bit more we'll talk about
congressional blowback on all this plus
president Trump has one nominee to a
federal position that has been largely
overlooked and there's no excuse for
overlooking this nominee because it's a
real problem plus there's a big new rig
big breaking news about a possible
Supreme Court vacancy we'll talk about
that but you're gonna have to go over to
daily wire.com for that so for $9.99 a
month you can subscribe to daily wire
comm when you do you get the rest of
this show live it's been part of my
mailbag so today right here in my hands
I
questions from the mailbag we only
answer questions from people who
subscribe and we answer live questions
from people who subscribe also we have
an episode of the conversation coming up
Tuesday March 13th 5:30 p.m. Eastern
2:30 p.m. Pacific featuring me subscribe
today to be a part of the conversation
and then I can answer your questions in
an hour long live Q&A my conversation
will stream live on the bench Shapiro's
Facebook page and The Daily wire YouTube
channel it'll be free for everyone to
watch only subscribers can ask the
questions to ask those questions as a
subscriber log in to our website daily
we're calm you head over to the
conversation page and you watch the live
stream and then you just start typing
your questions into the daily wired chat
books and a chat box and I will answer
those questions as they come in
for an entire hour unless you keep
asking about pudding as always guys once
again subscribe to get your questions
answered by me Tuesday March 13th 5:30
p.m. Eastern 2:30 p.m. Pacific and join
the conversation should get all of those
magical things with the subscription and
if you want this the very greatest in
all beverage vessels leftist here's hot
or cold tumblr all you have to do is get
the annual subscription for ninety nine
dollars a year it is cheaper than the
monthly and you will be refreshed and
emboldened by use of this beverage
vessel when you get the annual
subscription you just want to listen
free for for free later go over to
youtube go over to iTunes please
subscribe please leave us a review it
always helps us we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast in
the nation
so Congress obviously is pushing back
against the the president's tariffs but
are they really gonna push are they
really gonna do anything probably not
you know Senator Ron Johnson says listen
nobody wins a trade war this is gonna
harm consumers Ron Johnson is from one
of the states that Trump just won so you
might want to listen to him right he's
from Wisconsin and again if we start
engaging in trade wars I just don't
believe anybody wins a trade war quite
honestly there there may be people that
that are harmed less maybe America is in
a better position but I just think
there's so much collateral damage I
think it's a very risky and dangerous
strategy okay I obviously agree but the
question is gonna be what do you do
about it
what do you gonna do about it are you
actually going to stand up and tell
Trump no or I just gonna sit back and
watch and push this policy one of the
things that Trump has done is he's got
Republicans in Congress in terror of him
they think that if they fight him in any
way the Trump is just gonna come into
their district and shellac them or come
into their state and rip them publicly
and then they'll lose their Senate seat
I think that's overblown I don't think
Trump has that sort of sway I think
Alabama showed he doesn't have that sort
of sway Republicans need to stand up to
be had policy even if a Republican is
making it otherwise you are not doing
your job Republicans it is your job stop
this stuff you do have the legislative
authority
speaking of which Republicans in
Congress must stop the reen AMA nation
of one of trumps nominees okay this is
his nominees name when this nominees
name is high fell fell fell bloom -
bloom is a radical Obama appointee to
the Equal Employment Opportunity
Commission okay the EEOC has the power
to regulate industry all over the United
States to withdraw federal contracts
from any business that doesn't meet the
the dictates of the EEOC industries are
routinely sued under the by the EE under
the auspices of the EEOC and one of the
big issues that's now coming up is
whether the federal government is
allowed to contract with any business or
whether they have to crack down under
federal anti-discrimination law on
businesses that refuse to for example
use transgender people in particular
industries so you are religious own
bakery and Bob shows up tomorrow and he
calls himself Babette do you have to
keep employing Bob right so according to
- when the answer is yes you are a
Christian known bakery and a and you
contract the federal government you
provide all sorts of bagels to the
Troops or something and tomorrow a guy
comes in and he says
I want you to make a big bagel for my a
giant bagel for my gay wedding you say
listen I'm a Christian guy not
interested in doing that this comes up
before the EEOC how do they rule
these are serious questions the EEOC has
an enormous amount of power Daniel
Horowitz / a conservative review says
the same power the Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau wields over financial
institutions the EEOC wields over
property right societal norms and
discrimination laws
it holds unconstitutional
quasi-legislative and quasi judicial
powers to trump up and adjudicate
charges against businesses and colleges
over quotas and discrimination a lot of
people have been sued under the EEOC in
the private sector so this is this is
really troublesome the EEOC has
responsibility in the private sector
they don't process complaints of
discrimination for federal employees
those are filed with with other
enforcement agencies but they provide
according to the their website they
provide quality services that are fair
and prompt for both employees and
employers in our administrative
processing system and and their job is
to is to mediate and and provide
settlements they're responsible
providing hearings and appeals after the
initial processing of complaints by each
individual federal agency this usually
applies to federal contractors so all of
this is very troublesome so what is high
Feldblum doing hi fella wasn't obama
appointing and hi fella Blum has written
things like this quote when sexual
orientation and religious freedom come
into conflicts quote I'm having a hard
time coming up with any case in which
religious liberty should win sexual
Liberty should win in most cases there
can be a conflict between religious
liberty and sexual Liberty but in almost
all cases sexual Liberty should win
because that's the only way that the
dignity of gay people can be affirmed in
any realistic manner so in other words
if you are a religious Baker bake the
cake quote just as we do not tolerate
private racial beliefs that adversely
affect African Americans in the
commercial arena even if such beliefs
are based on religious views we should
similarly not tolerate private beliefs
about sexual orientation and gender
identity that adversely affect the
ability of LGBT people to live in the
world so again equate in black people
with gay people so I've said for a long
time I think hands high discrimination
law is largely unconstitutional I think
freedom of association means you do get
to be a racist in the United States and
then we all use our market power to put
you out of business okay that I think
that that's perfectly plausible and I
think that I think a very libertarian
view of this sort of stuff even on
issues of race and I'm a Jew wherein
Jews have you know been banned for
country clubs in the United States the
solution to that is build your own
Country Club but if you want to even say
the businesses should not be able to
discriminate against Jews or blacks that
does not mean that businesses don't have
the capacity to discriminate against
behavior his sexual orientation is one
thing sexual behavior is another the
idea that a business doesn't have the
capacity to turn down participation at
the same-sex wedding is asinine but
that's what this lady says she says for
all my sympathy for the evangelical
Christian couple who may wish to run a
bed-and-breakfast from which they can
exclude unmarried straight couples in
all gay couples this is a point where I
believe the zero-sum nature of the game
inevitably comes into play and in making
the decision in this zero-sum game I'm
convinced society should come down on
the side of protecting the liberty of
LGBT people and she even says that
granting Liberty to gay people advances
a compelling government interest and
that such an interest cannot be
adequately protected if pockets of
resistance to a societal statement of
equality are permitted to flourish ok
she is a she is an LGBT fascist when it
comes to the government crammed downs of
particular social issues and Trump is
renovating her to the EEOC that is
unacceptable it should be stopped by the
Senate there's no way this person should
be confirmed it is astonishing the
people in the Senate are not speaking
out more clearly about this I know some
people are looking Mike Lee from Utah is
one of those folks but you know it's
time for the Senate to stand up it's on
his hind legs just a little bit okay
time for a thing a couple of things I
like some things I hate and then we'll
get to the mailbag so things I like we
have been doing some heaven themed
things too this week so one of those
things really has nothing to with heaven
but there's some good exit there's some
good exploration of immortality and the
impact of immortality on how we think
and that of course is a fyodor
dostoyevsky's Brothers Karamazov one of
the great novels in human history it is
it is a fantastic novel there's great
disguise it's basically a philosophical
treatise in the form of a murder mystery
that's that's essentially how dusty
upski does is think crime and punishment
is the same sort of thing Brothers
Karamazov has a lot of talk specifically
about immortality and whether human
beings who don't believe in heaven can
construct moral systems that make any
sense there's a long conversation about
this in the famous chapter of the Grand
Inquisitor in which one of the brothers
Ivan tells the story of Jesus coming
back but coming back during the Spanish
Inquisition and the Grand Inquisitor
questioning Jesus about why it
constructed people with such flaws it's
a it's a fantastic book obvious
late this is I think the best version of
the translation by Richard heavy-r and
Larisa Volkonsky this is it's it's the
translation and these retro novels
really makes a difference there's a new
translation of born piece that makes a
huge difference over the old
translations this is a very good
translation I think so check that one
out
dusty Huskies Brothers Karamazov I've
never actually recommended that on the
program I believe which is a shocker
because that's obviously one of the
great novels in human history okay other
things that I like so this is just
really funny so there's this Democratic
legislature who decided that she was
going to show the world that she hates
her gun so she went and she got her air
15 from the closet and then she sawed it
off and she wanted to show everybody
that she was going to she was going to
make it unworkable so here is what she
did and then I will tell you what
happened next I wasn't happy about it
and after last week I told him I wanted
this gun out of my house okay so there
she goes and she's sawing right through
the barrel of the ar-15 and we've seen
this routine already the media features
it every time is joining moms the main
action I'm marching with the students
marching for their lives okay there's
only there's only one problem with all
of this this virtue signaling the the
ATF Alcohol Tobacco Firearms that agency
is now looking to prosecute her because
it's illegal to own a sawed-off shotgun
it's illegal to own a sawed-off rifle
you are not allowed to have a rifle that
has a short barrel because it is it is
capable of being concealed more easily
and also because the spray is greater
with a shotgun particularly like the
shorter the barrel is the greater the
spray is so she is actually now in
danger of prosecution for what she's
just so virtru signaling fail well done
lady just just a work of heartbreaking
genius again other things that I love
this is really funny so the New York
Times had issued one of the great
all-time Corrections in human history
yesterday so there was a New York Times
editor who who had to issue a correction
because there was a piece referring to
the Great Recession as quote the time of
shedding and cold rocks and why was it
referred to in the New York Times piece
the Great Recession as the time of
shedding and cold rocks because
apparently this person who is writing
the piece forgot to remove a Google
Chrome extension which changes certain
phrases to other phrases okay it is a it
is google extension that translate
Millennials to snake people okay so here
the correction from the New York Times
this is legitimate I'm reading this word
forward because of an editing error
involving a satirical text swapping
browser extension an earlier version of
this article swapped in the words time
of shedding and cold rocks in place of
the correct words Great Recession
spectacular stuff well done first of all
Millennials to snake people is just a
fantastic Chrome extension show well
done that's the best thing the New York
Times has done in years hey that just
great stuff okay time for a couple of
things that I hate all right so a couple
of things that I hate too last night I
was on Laura Ingraham show on Fox News
and one of the things we were discussing
was President Trump had held a forum at
the White House in which he discussed
the supposed threat of violent video
games right he suggested that violent
video games are creating more mass
shooters and they showed this montage of
what some of these violent video games
look like they're incredibly realistic
and of course they are incredibly
violent
[Music]
but I mean this stuff is really graphic
I mean it's pretty pretty terrible now
the here's the problem do I think this
stuff is really gross and terrible yes I
do think this stuff is gross and
terrible I would not let my children
play these games I remember when I was
younger I played a game called quake do
you guys remember quake or is that
before your time so quake was a very
popular game I believe that he made a
movie out of it at one point and it was
a first-person what they call a
first-person shoot him up Wolfenstein
was another popular well first-person
shoot him up when I was growing up these
are these are now obviously ancient
games and the graphics are really not
sophisticated but they were very bloody
obviously I'm not gonna say I didn't
grow up to grow up be a serial killer
because I can't tell you whether I did
or not but I will say the vast majority
of people who played quake did not go on
to shoot up schools and statistically
speaking the notion that violent video
games have led to an increase in
juvenile crime rates is not true it's
just not true as the as the rate of
violent video game playing has gone up
the rate of juvenile crime has gone down
and if you look at countries like Japan
violent video games are extraordinarily
popular in Japan juvenile crime is
extraordinarily low in Japan now what I
let my kids play this note because I
think that it does desensitize to
violence
I think that it is immoral to to get a
thrill from even fake killing innocent
people as you see in some of these
situations and I think there's certain
material that's just too graphic for
kids right so the reason why I wouldn't
show an r-rated movie to my to my
four-year-old I think there's just
there's there's some material that's not
appropriate but that's a parental
decision and just because we don't like
material this is an area where I've sort
of changed my opinion over time just
because we don't like material doesn't
mean that regulation of the material is
the best possible solution and it also
doesn't mean that we get to change the
social science data to reflect our
beliefs so what the statistics tend to
show is that there is a violence
desensitization effect with these games
but that doesn't necessarily manifest in
behavior and when people say that it
does manifest in behavior that may be
mistaken cause for effect you may be
looking at people who like violent
behavior and so they play violent video
games and we're taking it as though it's
a normal person who plays a violent
video game and then they want to engage
in violent behavior it's quite possible
that the polarity is the other way
around that the cause and effect is
actually reversed that there's a violent
kid who likes playing violent video
games because he's a violent kid and
there's no real way to tell that the
studies that have been done trying to
show whether people have been
transformed by these video games show
mixed data at best so I think it's
important to look
the data when we're talking about the
creation of public policy even though I
think that it's a culture we should
heavily discourage these sorts of games
from being played by children or young
teenagers okay other things that I hate
so it's amazing the entire left has said
that Donald Trump is the reality TV show
president we've never had anything like
him before it's completely unprecedented
well well now Obama is in advanced
negotiations when Kyle Griffin with
Netflix to produce a series of high
profile shows that will provide him a
global platform after his departure from
the White House people familiar with the
discussions tell the New York Times so
apparently Eric Schultz a senior adviser
to the former president issued a
statement president and mrs. Obama have
always believed in the power of
storytelling to inspire throughout their
lives they have lifted up stories of
people whose efforts to make a
difference are quietly changing the
world for the better as they consider
their future personal plans they
continue to explore new ways to help
others tell and share their stories so
so much for non reality TV show Obama he
is now going to invading your Netflix
with his latest series yes he was the
Hollywood President I said this at the
time when Trump was elected the the
great irony of the situation is that
Obama thought that he was this great
statesman who is not a reality TV
reality TV game show host and then he
had to look across the room at a guy who
is his direct polar polar mirror he's
like bizarro Superman make bizarro Obama
in the form of Trump both reality TV
show presidents one who considers
himself a great thinker and one who
considers himself an entertainer okay
time for the mailbag so if your
subscriber asked her questions now
Michelle says hi Ben
I have long been a champion of lazy
Farrakhan audits individualism and the
logic espoused by Iran the atheism and
raping love scenes in her work not so
much objective it's balke me when I say
logic and Christianity are not mutually
exclusive that Atlas Shrugged is their
Bible and iron ran their deity am i
wrong if not is there a way I can better
frame this argument no I mean I think
that you're not wrong this is a debate
that I'm supposed to have I believe with
yarn Brooke at some points I watched his
video responding to me on objectivism
and what it seems to me is that what
Objectivist tend to do is they redefine
virtue in Objectivist terms so
traditional virtue has suggested that
for example altruism is a virtue right
did Iran's his altruism and personal
relationships is a sin it's not a virtue
she says that altruism is a mistake
because selfishness is a virtue as it is
in the marketplace because in the
marketplace you have a creative impulse
to create that leads you to transform
the world and then you want to take that
creative impulse and you want to trade
that for more
pasady to fulfill that creative impulse
and that's how trade happens that's how
the world is better I totally agree with
this on an economic level on a personal
level I've always said that one of the
big fun of one of the funny things about
Iran's work is there never any children
to nine rounds work so yarn Brooke would
respond to my suggestion that if I were
to operate out of selfishness I'd
abandoned my children by saying well no
that would just be you operating out of
like your temporary selfishness but if
you're operating out of your long-term
selfishness you would realize that it is
worthwhile to do this except for the
fact that what objectivism does in the
moral sphere with regard to personal
relationships is it removes my ability
to judge whether a behavior is good or
bad I can't actually judge whether
somebody else's behavior is good or bad
because selfishness is by nature a
subjective phenomenon so I can judge
somebody if they're taking away from
somebody else right if they're if
they're a leech or a mooch a moocher and
under the the Iran terminology I can I
can do any of that but what I cannot do
in in the personal sphere is blame a
husband for leaving his wife and his
children because if he made the personal
calculation that his happiness would be
maximized by leaving his wife and his
children then Who am I to judge that and
my answer to that is I can judge that
any time because he just did something
wrong that is a wrong that makes the
world worse it makes his family worse
off he has wronged them because he made
a commitment and now he violated that
commitment and you know so the
Objectivist would say well what does the
commitment me and the commitment you
know why why should he fulfill his
commitment because in the future maybe
he has an interest in doing so the
problem is there's a there's a line and
I'd be interested to discuss this with
yarn actually there there's a line in
objectivism that seems to fall quickly
into subjectivism when it comes to your
your personal attitude toward those that
you care for and your personal activity
in moral behaviour Iran is a perfect
example of this right she ditched her
husband her her lover who's 30 years
younger and then she was ditched his
wife they got together
Dagny in in Atlas Shrugged is hopping
from bed to bed and everybody's just
sort of okay with it right all of her
former lovers are totally fine with this
this is giant mystery of how human
beings actually operate in the real
world hey Brennan says hello Ben I saw a
story on Facebook that has been getting
a lot of praise on conservative pages
but it disturbed me it's a video of a
ten-year-old boy who was accused of
bullying other children on the bus as
punishment he was not allowed to ride
the bus for three days his father
decided he was gonna make his son run
the mile to school every day for those
three
his punishment as someone who was
bullied in school what do you think
about the parents punishment I think
teaching your son not to bully by
bullying him doesn't seem like it's in
your child's best interest huge fan
thank you so much so I disagree I love
that story I think it's a great story I
think bullies should be punished by
their parents I think the way you get
bullies to stop bullying is by realizing
that the shoe can fit on the other foot
is by realizing that there are
consequences to your action okay it's
not through love bully's are not stopped
through love bullies are stopped when
they recognize that they can be on the
wrong end of the bullying and so perhaps
they should think again before doing so
Liam says hey Ben with all the turnover
in the White House recently would you
ever consider being one of trumps
advisors if a position was offered
thanks no no this is not my job my job
is to analyze as objectively as possible
from a conservative perspective what is
the Trump is doing and I don't think
that working for the Trump
administration frees me to do that and
more enjoy discussing ideas and
conversing with you than I would you
know flacking for a particular position
that I disagree with which is part of
the job when you work for the president
Christopher says hi Ben have you ever
been heard of sovereign citizens I
recently came across YouTube videos of
these people having bizarre interactions
with police officers when they refused
to identify themselves or show ID they
always claim they don't have to follow
laws because they do not consider
themselves citizens of the United States
is there any legal basis for their
argument Thanks so this is a great
philosophical question so there's no
legal basis their argument under
American law but the idea is if you are
born in America you're an American
citizen subject to the jurisdiction
thereof that's how American law worked
is how love virtually every country
works but it does pose a question for
social contract theory so if you look in
philosophy if you look at everyone from
walk through so there's this idea of
social contract theory that people were
living in a state of nature Hobbes talks
about this as well and that we all came
together and we formed a social contract
and then we decided to give up some of
our liberties essentially or at least to
hand over the cultivation of those
liberties to a broader a communal system
a government in order to protect us and
this is true in Locke it's true in
Hobbes it's true in Rousseau although
they have different definitions of the
state of nature and what it was that we
gave up when we exited the state of
nature in favor of a state system okay
but there's a question and what if you
are just born right you weren't born
into a state of nature you were born
into a state are you subject did you
consent to being part of that social
contract so Thomas Jefferson thought not
John Thomas Jefferson thought that you
actually had to with for a while in his
career anyway I think he revised it
later in life he thought that that you
actually had to opt into the system it
wasn't that you had the capacity to opt
out you actually had to opt in
and the typical answer given by folks
like lock or Hobbs is that the state of
nature was a temporary place once you
exited as a society that is now
incumbent on your children to live under
the laws of the state but social
contract theory the idea that everyone
is born into a state of nature and you
get to make your own decisions you have
your own sovereign so you get to decide
which country to live in you know that
is it's an interesting argument legally
it's not particularly an interesting
argument because obviously states do
have sovereignty over a certain amount
of land and that sovereignty continues
even if you wish not to be part of it if
you don't like it then you can move
somewhere off the grid which is you know
the best answer for sovereign citizens
living in the middle of Boise hi-de-ho
and then proclaiming to the cops that
you are not subject to the laws of Boise
Idaho is obviously a strategy for
winding up in jail Clayton says women
have become increasingly involved in
politics since the early 20th century
what effect you think the influence of
women in politics has had on the current
political landscape well again I like to
look at people as individuals I don't
think women and men are the same it
tends to be that in politics if you look
at the way that that political appeals
are done that emotional appeals more
often are tailored toward women and an
economic appeals are more often tailored
towards men I think that obviously women
as fully sentient and rational human
beings should be not only voting but
having a voice in our politics I think
that you know having women as a part of
politics is as change politics in the
United States no doubt I mean if you
look at the way that voting breaks down
this gender gap between women and men
has been part of American politics for a
long time I believe statistically
speaking Republicans would've won
virtually every election since 1940 if
it just been men voting that's not an
excuse for women not voting obviously
that's just a statement the Republicans
should make their case better to women
because women have a lot to add and
women have a lot to say and well I am
NOT a big fan of emotion in politics I
do think that Republicans can tailor
their message and and conservatives can
tailor their message to appeal to
emotion and also to recognize that some
emotional arguments are backed by logic
and just because the the emotion is high
doesn't mean the logic is missing Carr
says we all agree paying taxes suck but
what if we could pick and choose where
our taxes go I think it would be help it
would help our priorities to be heard
well I agree obviously I mean that's
what we're supposed to be doing with a
representative government it's why I
oppose omnibus packages omnibus packages
basically say you pay your taxes to the
giant government
here's a thousand page bill all your
money's gonna be distributed how we like
it
I
think that our representatives should
present to us each thing they want to
spend money on and then we should yell
at them until they stop on each one of
those things unless we like those things
and that would be a much better way of
doing things like Joshua says dear Ben
what is your take on whether individuals
should be able to fully fill the
automatic rifles during our revolution
we had the predecessor to the Gatling
gun called the Puckle gun love the show
keep up the good work so my view is that
fully automatic rifles do not justify
the risk the reason that I say that that
does not hold true for a semi-automatic
rifle is because semi-automatic rifles
have been used for literally generations
we were talking since the late 19th
century and not only that that is the
very minimum of a military weapon
military style weapon that would be
necessary in order to fight the
overreach of a tyrannical government I
do I think that you have to draw a
balance here because not every right
rights are not absolute and as Justice
Scalia said Justice Scalia's case in
Heller is that it's common use you know
weapons that were in common use at the
time those are those are not able to be
banned I don't see there are hundreds of
millions of guns in the United States
including tens of millions of rifles and
then includes semi automatics that's not
true of automatics which would basically
been banned in the United States since
the 1930s david says what do you think
of presidential drone strikes targeted
killings from a moral and legal
perspective so I don't have a problem
with drone strikes and targeted killings
against terrorists abroad I think where
this becomes a moral issue in Rand
Paul's view is when you are targeting
American citizens abroad I don't know
why drone strikes are particularly worse
than a soldier shooting somebody in the
head so this came up in the case of
Anwar al-awlaki who's an American
citizen abroad engaging in quasi
terrorist activity the question was was
he engaging in full-scale terrorist
activity that required us to shoot him
on the spot or was he engaged in
activity that required us to capture him
and bring him back for trial and it's
also holds true on American soil let's
say you have somebody who's engaged in a
terrorist cell in the United States can
you just drone them I can just drone an
American citizen well the usual answer
has been that if they are an immediate
threat to life sure just like if
somebody is robbing a bank and is
threatening a teller the police can
shoot that person but if you are as if
the suggestion is that we can use a
drone on an American citizen who's
providing a more attenuated risk then
the answer is no in my opinion Chris
says dear Ben you're well-read I've seen
many movies and have listened to a
substantial amount of music what are
some of your favorite artists both
modern and classic well that's a broad
question I think you'll have to go back
to things I like I've been doing this
for legitimately the last two years and
the list is
extensive and long you know I will say
that right now I'm on a Brahmans kick
I've been listening to a lot of Brahms
lately a lot of Bach lately
pizzaz Carmen has been in my rotation as
so fair bit of opera if you want you
want some great opera go go get the the
user-friendly version is go get some
classes the can invested Pavarotti and
you and you will get some some great
opera now Austin says what's the best
way to explain the necessity of the
second amendment and firearm ownership
to a non-american who may not understand
it well the best way to explain the
necessity of the second amendment is
that the history of the world is replete
with tyrannical regimes who have
confiscated firearms from their own
people or and run roughshod over their
own people or run roughshod over
sovereign citizens of another state and
having an armed in armed citizenry
willing to stand up to tyranny is a
prerequisite to Liberty even if those
arms are never used travis has been my
AP government teacher is very pro gun
control he sent me an article detailing
the gun control policies the founders
used including laws requiring armed
citizens to appear mandatory musters
where their guns would be inspected and
door-to-door surveys for appropriate
weapons which sounds outlandish for
today's America I'm very Pro Second
Amendment and want to remain respectful
but I also don't want to appear weak as
I'm the strongest defender in our class
how do I refute this so I'd actually
want to see the specific gun control
policies that he's talking about
my guess is laws requiring armed
citizens to appear at mandatory musters
was because there were militias right
there militias and if you were a citizen
between a certain age a certain age then
you were required to be in a militia in
certain states in the Union but that
wasn't to suggest that a few morons in
the militia that your gun would be
confiscated that's not quite the same
thing private citizens owned their arms
they showed up to muster for the militia
they still own their arms and they use
their arms for self defense they use
those arms for hunting and in the case
of the Shay's rebellion or the whiskey
rebellion these their arms from more
than that Paul says hey man I was
wondering how you stay so motivated and
energetic I'm in the last year of
college in Massachusetts I work out six
times a week an eat pretty well and I
lack motivation and much energy I know
about schedules I'm not sure that makes
me motivated to do an event what do you
do well I think that it's important to
actually lay out your day I think you
have to have a list of things you want
to get done in a day and you actually
have to say I'm gonna work on something
for two hours and no longer the easiest
thing to do is to burn yourself out on a
project and then you're just dead the
rest of the day the best thing to do is
to shift it sort of like interval
training you know interval training and
exercise is the idea that instead of you
just working out bench press for
our instead you do like a quick burst of
energy here that ik Westbrook of a quick
burst of energy there and you sort of
have muscle confusion I think the same
thing holds true and work so I'll do a
burst of energy where I do the show and
then I'll have a burst of energy where I
write bright articles and I'll have a
burst of energy where I work on my books
and I take frequent breaks I take a
break every hour every two hours get up
stretch walk around go for a walk and
going outside is really important when I
was living in Massachusetts it's really
hard it's hard not to be lethargic
living in Massachusetts in the winter
let me tell you when I was in Boston and
Massachusetts in the winter it is cold
outside you're not going outside and
this makes you lethargic and lazy
because you're stuck in one room the
entire day doesn't matter put on your
gloves put on your shoes go outside walk
around for 15 minutes come back and
you'll feel energized and better for the
day I think frequent breaks are actually
a useful useful thing final question
here josh says with all the upcoming
release of your new book on judah on the
downfall of judeo-christian and risk
Tootie Liam values are there any similar
books to read beforehand so that we can
have a better understanding of your
thought process thanks in advance Josh
so I there's a book that I've
recommended on the show before called of
the passion of the Western mind that I
think is really excellent I'm big fan of
that book I think that the story of
philosophy by Will Durant is a really
good primer on the history of Western
philosophy really worth reading there's
a book that I'm enjoying and using as a
resource a history political philosophy
edited by Leo Strauss that's it that's a
really good one
these are all effec tomes my passion in
the Western mind is probably the least
thick of those after virtue is another
book I've recommended on the show that
deals with some of these same issues
although I think I'm coming at it from a
slightly different angle by Alastair
MacIntyre that is worth reading as well
so those there are a few that that will
give you reading for the next four
months so when you finish that and then
we can talk and that's if you read fast
okay so we will be back here on Monday
with much much more and we'll find out
fallout from the North Korean meeting
whether that's going to happen how
that's gonna go down I'm sure there'll
be a lot to talk about there always is
I'm Ben Shapiro have a great weekend
[Applause]
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Aleksandr Oh
audios mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Joshua Oliveira the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright floor
publishing 2018